يريدون الحصول على المزيد الآن في
أمر الإخلاء في غزة وتحذيرات من
أنه قد يكون له
عواقب وخيمة. كبيرة المراسلين الدوليين لشبكة CNN
كلاريسا وارد موجودة في أشدود
إسرائيل فورست شمال غزة،
كلاريسا هذا الأمر لأكثر من
مليون شخص بمغادرة شمال غزة، هل هذا هو الأمر؟
حتى
ممكن غير ممكن ذئب على الإطلاق وكنا نرى
ذلك أه
من خلال المشاهد التي تجري
الآن وعلى مدار اليوم في
شمال غزة حالة من الفوضى والارتباك
الناس المذعورون يحزمون ما
يمكنهم انتزاعه من أمتعة وينطلقون بسياراتهم بعض  سيرا
على الأقدام ولكن بدون
وجهة واضحة وحقيقية لأنه بصراحة
ليس لدى هؤلاء الأشخاص مكان يذهبون إليه. لا يوجد
مكان آمن في الوقت الحالي في غزة، وحتى في جنوب
غزة، فإن الملاجئ مكتظة بالفعل بالفعل
على الرغم من الجهود التي يبذلها
المجتمع الدولي لمحاولة
تسهيل التوصل إلى اتفاق مع مصر.  بشأن
إنشاء بطاقة إنسانية
حتى الآن لم تكن تلك الجهود مثمرة
وسمعنا من رئيس
وكالة اللاجئين الفلسطينيين التابعة للأمم المتحدة الذي وصف أه
أمر الإخلاء الإسرائيلي خلال 24
ساعة بفظاعة قال إن غزة
تتحول بسرعة إلى
حفرة جحيم نحن  تمكنت من التحدث إلى
طالبة شابة في طب الأسنان تبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا، وهي في
شمال غزة، ولم تتمكن من
المغادرة بعد، وهي تشعر بالرعب لكنها تقول إنه
ليس لديها مكان تذهب إليه، ألقِ
نظرة، أنا في الواقع
مرعوب وأحاول عدم إظهار ذلك  هذا هو الحال ولكن
كل الوضع من حولنا يبدو
كما لو أنهم يقولون إنك قد تموت
في أي لحظة، ولا تعرف إذا كنت سأموت أم لا،
ولا أعرف حتى ما إذا كنت سأعيش
للدقيقة التالية، لذا نعم، إنه أمر
مرعب حقًا.  اسمع أصوات
الأطفال الصغار في منزلك كيف
تحميهم من
هذا نعم إنه في الواقع أمر مرعب
من مجرد
تخيل ما إذا كان أي شيء
سيحدث لهم وأه عندما
يحدث أي تبجح أود رؤية المظهر على
الأربعين عامًا  -ابن أخي، ابن أخي البالغ من العمر أربع سنوات،
سيبدو مرعوبًا، لذا فمن
المفجع حقًا أن تفقد أي أصدقاء
أو عائلة خلال ضربات
الأيام السبعة الماضية، نعم، هناك
صديقة خرجت بالفعل من
منزلها إلى منزل ابن عمها  المنزل عندما كانت
هناك كما لو كانت المنطقة
مستهدفة، لقد تم قصف المنزل
وذهبت كيف كانت
تحب حقًا المزاح كثيرًا
والضحك معنا كثيرًا على الرغم من
أنه في المدرسة كما تعلم على الرغم من أنه في
في المدرسة، مررنا بأوقات عصيبة، فهي
دائمًا تعرف دائمًا كيف تجعلنا
نضحك، آسف لا
تأسف، لا
تأسف، نحن فقط نريد
السلام، هذا كل شيء،
قالت يارا وولف إنها
وعائلتها يريدون المغادرة، إنهم يريدون ذلك
للوصول إلى بر الأمان، فإنهم ببساطة لا يعرفون
إلى أين يجب أن يذهبوا، ومن المهم أيضًا
أن نقول إن حماس في هذه الأثناء كانت
تطلب من الناس عدم المغادرة والبقاء في
أماكنهم والوقوف في مكانهم.